what is up everybody it's animac here
for anime uproar and in this video I
will be breaking down the true power and
ultimate master plan of Marshall D teach
also known as Blackbeard Blackbeard is a
former member of whitebeard's crew a
former warlord and one of the current
Emperors of the sea he is also the only
known character to ever possess two
devil fruits at the same time and in his
pirating career he has engaged in Epic
Battles against Whitebeard Shanks Ace
the revolutionaries cp0 and many others
Blackbeard is clearly an extremely
dangerous man whose ultimate plan goes
far beyond just becoming the pirate king
and the main thing that makes him so
dangerous is not the fact that he
possesses two overpowered devil fruits
it's something else entirely so let's
talk about about it before we get into
it quick thank you to Mech arena for
sponsoring this video I freaking love
Mecca anime like guren Lagan Code Geass
and Gundam but beyond just watching I
always wonder what it would be like to
actually operate a futuristic Mecca in
battle with Macarena I can now do that
anytime I want from the comfort of my
own smartphone Macarena is a competitive
5v5 shooter where you actually need
skill and strategy to win battles not
just money and speaking of strategy
Macarena just released the amazing
Pilots feature featuring 12 unique
Pilots that you can choose from Pilots
add a whole new depth of strategy and
gameplay variety and you can customize
your pilot skills to build Pilots that
fit your personality your play style and
your mechs macarena's got a ton
happening this month including an
awesome new Mech Orion battle pass
season 8 where you can get some amazing
new skins and a bunch of other goodies
and special events where you can win a
brand new weapon the superpower powerful
graviton beam Macarena is free to play
on Android and iOS right now and you can
use my personal link or scan the QR code
here on screen to get a free starter
pack worth 25 including a fire light
skin a prodigy crate and a plasma cannon
4 to help kick-start your game try it
out for yourself click that link in the
description to go download Macarena
right now my in-game ID is
406.91139 finally this video will
contain One Piece manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned Blackbeard is not only one
of the strongest and most dangerous
characters in one piece but he is also
one of the most mysterious and this
mystery goes all the way back to his
early childhood Marshall D teach was
apparently an orphan who joined the
Whitebeard Pirates at age 12 which was
28 years ago this means that young teach
was about 2 years old during the
infamous God Valley incident but more on
that later although we know almost
nothing about teachers earliest years we
do know that not long after he joined
the Whitebeard Pirates people started to
notice that there was something strange
about him some two years after teach
joined the Whitebeard Pirates this
Legendary Pirate crew engaged in an epic
battle against another Legendary Pirate
crew the Roger Pirates the fight lasted
for three days and three nights although
it ultimately ended with the two Crews
squashing the beef and exchanging gifts
but during these three days Shanks and
buggy encountered teach for the very
first time Shanks and buggy were
themselves just kids back then only a
year younger than teach and they were
part of Roger's crew this is when buggy
noticed that teach didn't sleep at all
throughout the entire three days of the
battle and there was even a rumor going
around that teach has never slept a day
in his entire life this led buggy to
conclude that teach must be some kind of
monster and this information gives
further legitimacy to Marco's comments
from chapter 577 where he states that
teach is not a normal human and that he
has an odd body this unexplained oddness
to his body could be the reason why he
is the only known human who was able to
consume two devil fruits at once and all
of this sparked a flurry of theories
about the true nature of Blackbeard's
body and the Mystery of his Origins I
will get back to all of this later but
we still need to trace the evolution of
Marshall D teach from a lonely orphan
turned Whitebeard Pirates crew member to
the ruthless yonko known as Blackbeard
after joining the Whitebeard Pirates at
the age of 12 teach spent over two
decades serving aboard the Moby Dick and
carefully performing his duties as a
member of the Whitebeard Pirates he
eventually became a member of the second
division and he actually went out of his
way to avoid attention and notoriety he
even passed up a promotion to Second
Division Commander because he claimed
that he didn't have that kind of
ambition so he encouraged Ace to accept
the position instead but the truth was
far more Sinister and teach his entire
decades-long stint as a member of the
Whitebeard Pirates was just one part of
his devious master plan for his entire
life teach had been looking for a very
specific and very special devil fruit
the unique and overpowered yamiyami no
me he joined the Whitebeard Pirates
because he believed that serving on
whitebeard's crew would maximize his
chances of encountering the yamiyami
Nomi it took a long time but teacher's
intuition turned out to be true the only
problem was that he wasn't the one who
found the yummy yummy Nomi the one who
found it was the fourth division
Commander batch because the Whitebeard
Pirates had a rule which stated that
whoever finds a devil fruit has the
right to eat it teach felt like he had
no choice he killed thatch before he
could eat the devil fruit stole the
yummy yummy Nomi for himself and
abandoned the white-beard Pirates
Marshall D teach then adopted the name
Blackbeard and formed his own crew the
Blackbeard Pirates according to
Blackbeard thatch finding the yamiyami
Nomi was just bad luck for him because
this fruit had already chosen Blackbeard
and he was always destined to become its
next user only a few months before the
straw hats arrived on drum Island
Blackbeard along with four other
crewmates attacked the island and
overthrew its ruler king waffle who then
fled the country that is our first real
introduction to Blackbeard in the story
although he and his crew only appear in
silhouette 4. at that time his crew was
composed of Lafitte former Sheriff from
the West Blue who after being fired for
excessive cruelty became Blackbeard's
Navigator Jesus Burgess the Helmsman doc
cued the ship's doctor and Van auger the
sniper now it's important to mention
that back when teach betrayed the
Whitebeard Pirates Ace made it his
mission to hunt him down in order to
avenge thatch Whitebeard warned Ace not
to go stating that he had a bad feeling
about this one but Ace just couldn't let
it go the Whitebeard Pirates were his
family Whitebeard was the only father
that he ever knew and so he couldn't let
Blackbeard get away with his treason as
a result Ace ventured out on a journey
to find his former crewmate and bring
him to Justice following the defeat of
crocodile in Alabaster Blackbeard's
Navigator Lafitte traveled to marijua he
somehow managed to gain access to a
meeting between sengoku and other
Warlords and he nominated Blackbeard as
a replacement for crocodile but at this
point in time Blackbeard was still a
nobody so Lafitte was told that his
captain would first need to grow his
reputation as an Infamous pirate before
he could become a warlord of the sea at
the same time the other members of the
Blackbeard Pirates including Blackbeard
himself were hanging out in mock town on
Jaya and that is where Blackbeard first
comes face to face with Luffy while
eating cherry pie inside a Tavern in
mocktown Blackbeard and Luffy both yell
out at the barkeep at the same time but
while Luffy says that the Cherry Pie is
so bad that he could die Blackbeard says
just the opposite the Cherry Pie is so
good that he could die this instantly
creates a sense of tension between them
and this only escalates once they try
their drinks Blackbeard hates the drink
while Luffy loves it and before you know
it the two Pirates have already become
Rivals they start trying to one-up each
other in terms of who will order more
food to go and their argument nearly
breaks out into a fight before NAMI
intervenes Blackbeard then asks Luffy
whether he is a pirate and Luffy
confirms that he is and that his Bounty
is 30 million Blackbeard refuses to
believe this and he even calls Luffy a
liar but before their conflict can
progress any further the barkeep gives
Blackbeard his 50 cherry pies to go and
sends him on his way after Luffy's Zorro
and Nami are mocked bullied and laughed
out of the tavern for believing that the
sky island is real Blackbeard actually
Praises them he says that the new age of
pirates that Bellamy and the others
inside the tavern spoke of is rubbish as
you'll recall Bellamy tried to argue
that the age of Dreams is over and that
the Pirates who believe in fairy tales
like the sky island or the City of Gold
are losers who are going to get
themselves killed for nothing but
Blackbeard proclaims that the age of
pirate dreams cannot be over because
people's dreams don't ever end
Blackbeard then bids farewell to the
straw hats and he says that he hopes
that they will make it to Sky Island in
my mind this scene establishes
Blackbeard as a truly fascinating
character in some ways he is the polar
opposite of Luffy someone who has the
opposite taste from Luffy someone who
uses completely different tactics than
Luffy does and someone who meticulously
plans and schemes while Luffy Just Wings
it as he goes and yet there is one thing
that the two of them have in common they
both have big crazy dreams that others
mock as unrealistic including the dream
to One Day become the pirate king
although I think that Blackbeard's dream
is even bigger than that and becoming
the pirate king is just another stepping
stone for his true ultimate goal but
more on that later interestingly enough
as Nami Luffy and Zoro part ways with
Blackbeard both Luffy and Zoro state
that Blackbeard is not just one guy some
have interpreted this as Luffy and Zoro
being aware that Blackbeard's other
crewmates are also there in mocktown but
others believe that Luffy and Zorro
sensed that there are multiple people
within Blackbeard's body a theory that I
will explain later on when we get into
the strange properties of Blackbeard's
powers and abilities when they first met
in mocktown Blackbeard wasn't aware of
the fact that Luffy's new post Alabaster
Bounty was actually one 100 million
berries when he learns that this is the
case Blackbeard decides to capture Luffy
and claim his bounty in order to make a
name for himself which would of course
clear the path for him becoming a
warlord Blackbeard does manage to catch
up to the straw hats off the coast of
Jaya but he loses them after the going
Mary gets caught in the knock-up Stream
the knock-up stream also damages
Blackbeard's ship and so Blackbeard
chooses to end his Pursuit because he is
sure that he and Luffy will meet again
on the grand line Blackbeard made the
decision to pursue the straw hats once
again after the events of NS Lobby when
Luffy's bounty shot all the way up to
300 million berries however before he
can go after Luffy he is stopped by Ace
who finally manages to track down
Blackbeard on banero island in chapter
440 of the manga Blackbeard actually
tries to convince Ace to join his crew
so that together they could take over
the world starting with taking out Luffy
at water 7. but Ace reveals that Luffy
is his brother and that he would never
join Blackbeard members of Blackbeard's
crew then attack Ace but they get
wrecked so hard that Blackbeard warns
them to stay away because they are not
on Ace's level this shows us that
despite being extremely ruthless in the
pursuit of his dream Blackbeard does
value his crewmates and he doesn't think
of them as completely disposable
although it is possible that he only
values them because he needs their help
in order to achieve his dream Blackbeard
then reveals the true nature of his
devil fruit for the very first time just
as Ace's body is made of fire because he
consumed the merame thanks to the
yamiyami Nomi Blackbeard's body is made
of darkness and according to Blackbeard
even among the extremely rare logia
devil fruits his fruit is a rarity in
fact Blackbeard claims that this is the
most dangerous power in the history of
devil fruits suddenly dark tendrils
begin shooting out from beneath
Blackbeard and they eventually engulfed
the entire town Blackbeard explains that
darkness is gravity and his Darkness has
the ability to suck everything in
including light itself Blackbeard then
activates an ability called black hole
and a whole town including entire
buildings is sucked into Blackbeard's
Darkness he explains that his dark
gravity compresses objects with infinite
power and crushes them he then activates
an ability called Liberation which
shoots out the town back out of the
darkness but the town is now in ruins
the large houses and buildings are now
nothing but piles of rubble Blackbeard
has utterly destroyed an entire town in
mere seconds this grandiose display was
clearly intended to intimidate Ace but
it doesn't work Ace simply commences his
fiery attack on Blackbeard and it is
clear from the start that Aces fire is
successfully hurting Blackbeard this
surprises Ace because physical attacks
of this type should not be able to hurt
a logia user but Blackbeard explains
that his Darkness sucks everything in
including punches blades bullets and
lightning this means that Blackbeard
can't just turn his body into darkness
and allow attacks to pass through him
like other logia users instead all
attacks are absorbed by his darkness and
he will feel the pain from those attacks
worse yet the pain of every attack will
actually be Amplified it is a grave and
painful sacrifice but in exchange
Blackbeard can use black Vortex an
ability which allows him to pull in the
actual body of devil fruit users and
then once Blackbeard is directly
touching the body of a devil fruit user
his Darkness can actually negate the
power of that user's devil fruit this
means that while he is touching Ace
Blackbeard can punch him and deal other
types of physical damage to him because
Ace cannot turn his body into fire
simply put while Blackbeard is directly
touching their bodies devil fruit users
will lose the ability to use their devil
fruit Powers so Blackbeard can
essentially turn even the strongest
devil fruit user into a normal human
being Ace tries to avoid this
predicament by making sure that
Blackbeard doesn't get close enough to
actually touch him but black Vortex is
extremely difficult to avoid since it's
basically an all-encompassing dark
gravity Ace fights bravely and valiantly
and he puts Blackbeard through a lot of
searing pain with his fiery attacks
Ace's fighting capability is so
impressive both with and without his
devil fruit powers that Blackbeard
offers him yet another chance to join
him but Ace refuses to bow down to a
traitor he refuses to live his life
dishonorably and full of regrets ever
the realist Blackbeard says that nothing
else matters if you're dead so avoiding
death is the most important thing soon
The Duel between the fiery sun and the
all-encompassing Darkness engulfs all of
banaro Island and this duel ultimately
serves as a trigger for major world
shaking events that follow the actual
outcome of the battle is not shown on
screen but we later learned that
Blackbeard defeated Ace and delivered
him to the Marines in exchange for being
named a warlord of the sea which as we
know is a title that he has been trying
to secure since Jaya but just like
practically every other move in his life
Blackbeard's acquiring of the position
of warlord was simply a means to an end
it was just one piece in the much bigger
puzzle that is his ultimate master plan
as Ace awaits his execution at
marineford and as the Marines prepare
for war with the Whitebeard Pirates Who
are determined to rescue ways Blackbeard
uses his status as a warlord and an ally
of the world government to break into
impel down once there he releases and
recruits some of the world's most
powerful and most dangerous criminals
into his crew including shiryu Katarina
Devon Vasco shot San Juan wolf and avalo
Pizarro now stronger than ever before
the Blackbeard Pirates sailed to Marine
Ford in order to initiate the next phase
of Blackbeard's master plan and of
course the Blackbeard Pirates don't go
to Marine 4 to uphold their
responsibility as allies of the world
government nor do they go to support the
Whitebeard pirates in fact in chapter
576 Blackbeard straight up tells sengoku
that the only reason why he became a
warlord in the first place was so that
he could open the gates of justice and
infiltrate impel down without raising
suspicion this is what he had been
planning from the beginning and now the
that his mission has been accomplished
he no longer needed the title warlord as
we find out soon enough the reason for
Blackbeard's Presence at Marine Ford
despite already accomplishing one major
part of his plan at impel down is to
accomplish yet another even more
important part of his plan but before we
get into that we really have to stop and
consider just how cold and calculating
Blackbeard is at this point in the story
he had been making moves to become a
warlord for over 300 chapters since all
the way back in Jaya and yet it was all
just a means to an end it was all just
so he could spend an hour or two
infiltrating gamepal down and boosting
his crew with some of the world's most
dangerous criminals after that his
career as a warlord was over and the
very next moment it was on to the next
phase of his master plan this man is an
absolute Menace and not just because of
his crazy physical Powers but also
because of his incredibly sharp and
ruthless Machiavellian mind Blackbeard
and his crew then choose an opportune
time to launch a coordinated strike on
Whitebeard the man who possesses one of
the world's strongest devil fruits at
this point Whitebeard is already
severely injured and on the brink of
death so Blackbeard sees this as the
perfect time to strike he uses his
Darkness to cancel out the effects of
the guragura Nomi whitebeard's powerful
earthquake inducing devil fruit the
guragura Nomi is believed to be the
strongest paramecia devil fruit in
existence and it is said to be so
powerful that it can destroy the entire
world the user of this devil fruit can
create massive shock waves and Tremors
that can pass through anything including
the ground the sea floor and even the
air now confident of his victory
Blackbeard begins to use some taknojutsu
which is one of his rare weaknesses
instead of just focusing on finishing
the fight as quickly and effectively as
possible Blackbeard likes to talk during
his battles and he likes to brag and
talk down to his opponent this loss of
focus can't come back to haunt him as it
does during his confrontation with
Whitebeard Blackbeard says that he
respected Whitebeard and looked up to
him but he got old and he became weak he
couldn't even save one of his division
commanders from being publicly executed
by the Marines and so the era of
Whitebeard has come to an end and the
new era of Blackbeard is about to begin
but as Blackbeard attacks his former
Captain with black Vortex all the while
bragging about the fact that Whitebeard
can't use his devil fruit Whitebeard
just slashes Blackbeard's shoulder with
his physical weapon the murakumogiri
Blackbeard is shocked that Whitebeard
still has the physical strength to fight
after sustaining all of those injuries
and a fierce Whitebeard proclaims the
that overconfidence and carelessness are
Blackbeard's weaknesses now I would
certainly agree with the part about
overconfidence especially during battles
and I also agree that this
overconfidence does lead Blackbeard to
become more careless than he should be
again during battles however I think
that overall Blackbeard is anything but
careless he is a cold and calculating
schemer and strategist of the highest
quality and he carefully bides his time
for years and even decades before making
his move Whitebeard then grabs
Blackbeard by the throat as Blackbeard
cries and pleads for his life calling
Whitebeard pops and saying that he's
whitebeard's son many have pointed to
this moment as evidence that Blackbeard
is actually a coward who is afraid to
die however this could just be at
another case of Blackbeard being
strategic and Machiavellian he knows
that for Whitebeard family is the single
most important thing and so by appealing
to the idea that he is whitebeard's son
Blackbeard is doing the one thing that
is most likely to preserve his own life
by getting Whitebeard to show him Mercy
Whitebeard ultimately goes on to slam
Blackbeard into the ground while sending
a Tremor through his body but Blackbeard
survives Blackbeard then orders his men
to attack Whitebeard with everything
they've got and all the Blackbeard
Pirates proceed to shoot and stab
Whitebeard at the same time Blackbeard
feels no shame about the fact that he
couldn't even defeat an injured
Whitebeard one-on-one and that he had to
rely on his entire crew to take him out
again what matters to Blackbeard is not
honor or Pride the only thing that
matters is the end game and he is
prepared to do whatever it takes no
matter how shady and dishonorable as
long as it leads him to that desired
result as Whitebeard dies proudly and on
his feet he tell Blackbeard that despite
being a member of the d-clan he is not
the man that Roger was waiting for he
also says that the one piece is indeed
real and when it is found the whole
world will be turned upside down
Whitebeard then dies in what has to be
one of the most glorious and epic deaths
in the history of anime and manga but
while I could talk all day about the
extreme childliness of Whitebeard that
is a topic for another video and we need
to get back to Blackbeard the Blackbeard
Pirates then proceed to place a giant
piece of black cloth over whitebeard's
dead body and Blackbeard goes under the
cloth while the other crewmates keep the
Marines at Bay once he emerges from
beneath the cloth Blackbeard and
whitebeard's bodies don't look any
different but Blackbeard is suddenly
able to use not only his own devil fruit
the Yami Yami no me but he is also able
to use whitebeard's Old Devil fruit the
guragura Nomi at the same time it still
hasn't been explained how exactly he was
able to become the first person in
history who was able to use two
different devil fruits but Blackbeard
seems to imply that this is due to the
unique power of the yamiyami Nomi now in
possession of the strongest paramecia
devil fruit and the strongest logia
devil fruit Blackbeard declares that his
era begins there are many theories for
how exactly Blackbeard was able to
obtain a second devil fruit some believe
that Blackbeard brought a regular fruit
with him under that black cloth he
waited for whitebeard's devil fruit to
be reincarnated as the nearest suitable
fruit which is the fruit that Blackbeard
brought with him and then Blackbeard
somehow managed to use the yamiyami Nomi
which absorbs everything to absorb the
new guragura Nomi but even if his
Darkness was able to absorb the guragura
Nomi how is Blackbeard's body able to
handle using two devil fruits at the
same time why is his body so odd as
Marco puts it and is this oddness really
the reason why he became the only known
man to ever use two devil fruits at once
there are numerous popular theories
about the true nature of Blackbeard's
body why he doesn't seem to need any
sleep and why he is able to use two
devil fruits at once the most popular
theory is that Blackbeard is not just
one person but rather two or even three
people who are somehow sharing the same
body this could be a case of Blackbeard
having split personality disorder and so
when one personality is asleep another
one awakens which is why Blackbeard
himself never seems to sleep this could
also explain why back in mocktown Luffy
and Zorro seemed to suggest that
Blackbeard was not just one guy and it
could explain how Blackbeard was able to
fool the Whitebeard pirates for so long
maybe one of his personalities really
was genuinely loyal to the Whitebeard
Pirates and that personality really
didn't have any diabolical Ambitions but
once the yamiyami Nomi appeared
Blackbeard's more Sinister personality
took over and if Blackbeard Harbors
multiple personalities inside of him
then maybe that is how he is able to use
more than one devil fruit maybe each
devil fruit is somehow being used by a
separate personality it has been
suggested that there may actually be
three different personalities within
Blackbeard and that is why his Jolly
Roger features three different skulls
one beside the other another theory is
that we are not talking about multiple
personalities within one person but
rather we have a case of multiple real
people or at least multiple Souls
residing within Blackbeard's body
according to this Theory Blackbeard has
the ability to absorb The Souls of other
people and there could already be
multiple Souls trapped inside of him
although sly slightly different the
implications of this Theory are similar
to the implications of the split
personality theory Blackbeard doesn't
sleep because the souls inside of him
take turns sleeping he can use multiple
devil fruits because each Soul uses a
separate fruit and so on and then
there's the simplest Theory which is
that Blackbeard isn't multiple people
but the yamiyami Nomi itself just
changed his body and made it odd in the
first place this wouldn't explain why he
didn't sleep when he was younger before
he ever ate the yummy yummy Nomi but
perhaps he just didn't sleep during
battles because he didn't want to get
caught off guard by the enemy and this
then turned into an inaccurate rumor
that he never sleeps at all there is
even a theory that the yamiyami Nomi is
not actually a special logia rather it
is secretly a mythical Zone but
Blackbeard chooses to keep this
information hidden in order to maintain
the advantage over his opponents we made
an entire video about this Blackbeard
mythical Zone Theory and if you want to
check it out I will link it down in the
description okay so regardless of how
exactly Blackbeard was able to consume a
second devil fruit the act of absorbing
the guragura Nomi emboldened him and he
decided to use it to sink all of marine
Ford but before he could do this sengoku
appeared in his Buddha form and managed
to prevent Blackbeard from sinking the
entire Island Blackbeard acknowledges
that he still isn't able to fully
control the power of the guragura Nami
but he remains cocky and he tells
sengoku and GARP that they have become
obsolete just like Whitebeard Blackbeard
declares that no one can stop him
because he will destroy everything he
will swallow up everything but once
yonko Shanks and the red-haired Pirates
arrive at Marine Ford Blackbeard decides
that he already has what he wants and
this is not yet the time for him to
fight shanks sold the Blackbeard Pirates
depart as the Paramount war of
marineford finally comes to an end
speaking of Shanks he seems to know
Blackbeard's true nature better than
anyone Shanks has been warning about the
danger that Blackbeard poses to the
world for a long time and he had
cautioned Whitebeard about Blackbeard on
multiple occasions Shanks also has a
history with Blackbeard not only did the
two of them meet as children during that
battle between the Roger Pirates and the
Whitebeard Pirates but at some point
before the start of the series Shanks
and Blackbeard fought as adults and that
scar over Shanks his left eye was given
to him by none other than Blackbeard
himself Shanks seems to believe that
Blackbeard represents the single biggest
threat to the world of one piece and the
fact that an overpowered yonko like
Shanks worries so much about him speaks
volumes about the true extent of
Blackbeard's power after the events at
Marine Ford the Blackbeard Pirates start
making moves in the new world at some
point they defeat and captured jewelry
Bonnie a pirate captain in her own right
and a member of the worst generation
Blackbeard tells a tied up Bonnie that
she is too weak to lead her own crew in
the new world and that she is too weak
to join his crew but if she wanted to
become his woman he would oblige her say
what you want about this man but he does
have taste Bonnie refuses of course and
kicks Blackbeard in the head meanwhile
since Bonnie is a wanted pirate Captain
Blackbeard was planning to trade her to
the Marines in exchange for a new
Battleship because the raft belonging to
the Blackbeard Pirates was nearly
destroyed by the sheer size of San Juan
wolf however van auger informs
Blackbeard that akinu is aboard the
Marine Battleship which means that the
Marines are not interested in trading
with the Blackbeard Pirates rather akinu
is almost certainly planning to destroy
them ever the realist Blackbeard knows
that he is not yet ready for that fight
so he flees along with his crew leaving
Bonnie behind this once again shows us
that things like honor and glory mean
nothing to Blackbeard his priority is to
survive and to accomplish his mission
and he doesn't see any shame in running
away when the circumstances call for it
but Blackbeard would continue to advance
his goals in the new world and about a
year after the Marine Ford War so during
the time skip the Blackbeard Pirates
defeated the remnants of the Whitebeard
Pirates under the command of Marco and
took control of whitebeard's former
territory in order to accomplish this
task Blackbeard used his intimate
knowledge of the Whitebeard pirates and
their territory knowledge that he had
spent over 20 years accumulating and
that is how he ultimately triumphed in
what became known as the payback war
after this Blackbeard was officially
recognized as one of the four Emperors
of the sea Blackbeard became
ayanko the Blackbeard Pirates also
expanded from a crew to a fleet with
Blackbeard himself becoming their
Admiral and other pirate Crews have been
absorbed into the Blackbeard Pirates
including for example the peach beard
Pirates Blackbeard appears to be trying
to convince former Admiral aokiji to
join his Fleet and we know that the
Blackbeard Fleet is now actively hunting
down people with powerful devil fruits
in order to steal their devil fruit
abilities in fact in chapter 925 we
learned that the Blackbeard Pirates
killed Absalom stole his clear clear of
fruit and gave it to shiryu when Gekko
Moria went to looking for Absalom on
hachinosu island the headquarters of the
Blackbeard Pirates he was informed of
absalom's death and he witnessed
firsthand that shiru of the rain now
possesses the clear clear fruit Black
Beard then told morya that he might as
well join the Blackbeard Fleet because a
big Showdown for the throne is coming
the Blackbeard Pirates would go on to
attack the headquarters of the
Revolutionary Army on the island of
baltigo the island itself was destroyed
but the Revolutionary Army was a able to
escape once Cipher pole arrived at the
scene the Blackbeard Pirates engaged in
a brief clash with them before departing
we don't know why exactly Blackbeard was
so interested in attacking the
revolutionaries but I'm sure that it's
part of his wider master plan that has
been in the works since he first joined
the Whitebeard Pirates it's possible
that Blackbeard was after some powerful
devil fruits possessed by the members of
the revolutionaries or he might have
been after something else like an
ancient weapon in chapter 956 so one
chapter before we learn about the God
Valley incident we see Blackbeard
ordering his crew to pack their bags
because he intends to claim a certain
prize before the Marines have a chance
to take it we can't be sure what exactly
this mysterious prize is but with the
recent reveal that pluton is actually in
wano I expect that Blackbeard's next big
mission will be explained very soon he
is certainly after something big and
this this new mission may even be
connected to the reason why he attacked
the revolutionaries I can't wait to get
more information on Blackbeard's current
whereabouts and plans it should go
without saying that Blackbeard is
physically overpowered he is easily one
of the strongest men alive and even his
fellow yonko Shanks believes that
Blackbeard is the single greatest threat
to the world Blackbeard possesses
practically superhuman physical strength
and endurance he has two of the
strongest devil fruits in the history of
the world he has the power to steal the
devil fruits of other people and he is
the commander of one of the strongest
fleets that includes some of the most
dangerous criminals and warriors in
existence the Blackbeard Pirates are a
global superpower and the fact that they
are willing to do whatever it takes to
achieve their goals without regard to
law or morality makes them all the more
dangerous and since we still don't
actually know how Blackbeard was able to
use two devil fruits at the same time we
can't know for sure that he can't use
even more he may even be trying to pull
off a devil fruit Trifecta by consuming
the strongest logia paramecia and Zone
devil fruits he arguably already has the
strongest logia in paramecia so the only
one left is a Zone and that could mean
that he is coming after Luffy's newly
revealed hitohito no me model Nika and
you know what this means right it means
that we might be closer to an epic Clash
between the straw hats and the
Blackbeard Pirates than we realize and
since Shanks and Blackbeard have such a
long and complex relationship it is
almost certain that any Arc that would
involve Luffy fighting Blackbeard would
also involve Shanks and the red-haired
Pirates personally I've been waiting for
the Luffy and Shanks versus Blackbeard
Showdown for a very long time so I
honestly can't wait to see what Oda has
in store for us in terms of their final
character arcs so yeah I think we all
recognize that Blackbeard is one of the
strongest characters in the world of one
piece and that his Fleet is now one of
the strongest powers in the world but
I'm here to tell you that in spite of
his tremendous physical strength and
despite the fact that he possesses two
of the world's strongest devil fruits
Blackbeard's true strength comes from
his cunning manipulative and
Machiavellian mind and from his
Relentless determination to succeed at
all costs just like Luffy is propelled
forward by the force of his dream of
becoming the pirate king Blackbeard is
driven by his dream of becoming not only
the pirate king but also the Undisputed
king of the world I believe that
Blackbeard isn't just interested in
becoming the pirate king the strongest
pirate and the freest man on the Seas I
believe that Blackbeard is attempting to
carry out the will of Rock's D zebic who
wanted to overthrow the celestial
dragons and become the king of the world
after all Blackbeard chose to make his
pie pirate headquarters on hachinosu
island the very Island where the Rocks
Pirates were formed and he chose to name
his own Flagship the saber of zebic
clearly Blackbeard is deliberately
following in zebex footsteps but why
what is his connection to zebik and what
is his ultimate master plan Rox D zebic
was an extremely strong and ambitious
pirate who was very interested in the
secret history of the world he was also
arguably the greatest rival that Roger
ever had he was determined to get his
hands on Forbidden Knowledge and he
openly declared war on the world
government vowing to overthrow the
current system and become king of the
world more than 40 years ago he gathered
his crew on the island of hajinosu a
crew which consisted of a young kaido
Whitebeard big mom Shiki and Captain
John among others and then 38 years ago
he launched an attack on a mysterious
island called God Valley according to
sengoku multiple Celestial dragons were
present on God Valley at the time of the
attack it is possible that these were
high-ranking World Nobles maybe even the
gorosei because in order to defeat zebek
and protect the celestial dragons the
world government did something that was
Unthinkable and unprecedented they
teamed up with the future pirate king
Goldie Roger in order to defeat zebek
and his crew GARP and Roger actually
worked together to bring zebek down and
it was during this battle that GARP
earned the title hero of the Marines
after what must have been one of the
greatest battles in the history of One
Piece zebek was allegedly killed and the
Rocks Pirates were dissolved the truth
about the entire incident was then
censored by the world government and the
island of God Valley itself vanished
from the face of the Earth but even
though everyone except a few select
individuals from the older Generations
seems to have forgotten about zebek
Blackbeard has not forgotten he hasn't
forgotten zebik despite the fact that he
would have been only two years old when
zebek apparently died and he seems to be
on a mission to pick up where zebek left
off did Blackbeard somehow learn about
zebek and decide that he agreed with
zebek's life philosophy or is there a
more personal connection between the two
of them for example is Blackbeard
actually zebek's son who became an
orphan after zebbing's death and who
then decided to dedicate his life to
getting revenge for his father there is
also the theory that zebek was the
previous owner of the yummy yaminomi and
so when Blackbeard consumed the fruit he
also inherited the will of zebek
whatever the connection between
Blackbeard and zebic may be there
definitely is a connection and I'm
convinced that just like zebic
Blackbeard wouldn't be content with
becoming the pirate king no Blackbeard
wants to be king of of the world
Blackbeard wants to sit on the empty
throne and that means that he not only
poses a threat to Luffy Shanks and the
heroes of the story but also to imusama
the gorosei and the other Celestial
dragons I honestly tend to agree with
shanks's take on Blackbeard I do believe
that Blackbeard is the most dangerous
pirate and the single biggest threat to
the world he's been a man on a mission
since early childhood he joined the
Whitebeard pirates for a very specific
purpose and he then spent over 20 years
patiently waiting until the time came
for his purpose to be fulfilled and when
that time did come Blackbeard was
willing to do whatever it took to take
what he wanted he was willing to cross
any and all lines including the murder
of a comrade and he did it without
hesitation afterwards he fled the
Whitebeard Pirates and started his own
crew and his scheming only intensified
from this there he spent a long time
plotting to become a warlord and once he
finally attained that position he used
it to break into impel down and launch
the next phase of his plan immediately
afterwards he took advantage of an
opportune time to launch a sudden attack
on Whitebeard killing him and stealing
his devil fruit this was followed by a
strategic Retreat and then a year-long
conflict ensued with the remnants of the
Whitebeard Pirates Blackbeard used his
extensive knowledge of the Whitebeard
pirate crew and their territory to
defeat them and take their territory for
himself becoming a Yanko in the process
I mean this man's entire life has been
dedicated to one big master plan that is
only now beginning to finally reveal
itself and he is of course still
plotting and scheming attacking the
revolutionaries one day then fighting
the world government the next all the
while he is stealing powerful devil
fruits and distributing them among the
members of his own Fleet and unlike
Luffy shanks ARP dragon and the other
heroic characters of our story there is
no line that Blackbeard wouldn't be
willing to cross in order to achieve his
ultimate goal he is prepared to lie
cheat steal and kill in order to get his
way he is prepared to flee without any
regards to honor when the opportunity
requires it and he is also prepared to
sneak up on a Target and plunge a dagger
in their back without a second thought
his powerful Fleet and incredible devil
fruit Powers aside Blackbeard superb
scheming and strategizing and his
complete lack of moral or ethical
boundaries make him a gigantic threat to
someone like Luffy someone who likes to
rush in without a plan and someone who
definitely would not be willing to cross
the same moral lines that Blackbeard is
prepared to cross this is why Blackbeard
is way stronger and way more dangerous
than most people realize it's not just
about His stunning physical power it
also about his cunning Machiavellian
mind and his superhuman dedication to
finishing what zebik started I wouldn't
be surprised if instead of imusama and
the world government the final villain
of One Piece turns out to be none other
than Blackbeard himself and honestly I
would be all for it since Blackbeard is
the most fascinating villain in one
piece at least in my opinion but let me
know what you guys think do you like
Blackbeard as a character and do you
think that he will be the final villain
in the story how much of a threat do you
think that he poses to Luffy Shanks and
the other Heroes and could Blackbeard
succeed where zebic failed also what is
his connection to zebik don't forget to
share your thoughts down in the comments
below if you enjoyed this extensive
Blackbeard video and you want to see
more one piece content on the channel
leave a quick like to let me know it
really helps me with that YouTube
algorithm and of course if you want to
see more videos in the future don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell you can also hit me up
on Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
thanks again to Macarena for sponsoring
this video check them out Link in the
description as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya Space Cowboys